[Musik]
das ist warum aber ich werd dich brand
hat ja auch sie aber mit dem gesetz
betroffen hat eine struktur jetzt trag
ist also einfach ihren einfach das bild
ich habe ich gemacht worden und ich habe
eine frage der ethik kann sabara
monatelange der blog
[Musik]
es war ein heftiger tritt ein akku der
annina rhone aus dem tritt brachte eine
kurze unachtsamkeit mit schlimmen folgen
schwere verletzungen im gesicht und
nachhaltiger narben auf der seele
trotzdem die groß tierärztin macht
weiter wie bekämpft sie ihre angst im
stall was bleibt nach dem schock davon
handelt dieser film
eine gewisse unsicherheit begleitet die
groß tierärztin annina rohner jedes mal
wenn sie aus rückt die arbeit mit kühen
und pferden ist nicht ungefährlich
der erste auftrag an diesem kalten
wintermorgen eine kuh mit clown
entzündung bei einer solchen behandlung
erhielt annina rohner eine klaue mitten
ins gesicht
[Musik]
die kühe können hier in einem stand
sauber eingespannt werden
zeitdruck unachtsamkeit und eine
schlechte sicherung der kuh
dies waren die gründe für den unfall vor
gut einem jahr und hat sie abrichten
boxen und da also ich habe zu machen und
ihren kunden dem vorsingen und sagt
einfach nicht gemacht und dann noch
nicht sagen kann oder sie würden lieber
und die dem moment ist dann immer hat
sie geschlagen und ich weiß dass alle
frauen im gesicht hat es doch und dann
hatte ich ihnen abgeschmiert er wurde ja
genug machen und dadurch löst dich
glaubst nicht mitnimmt sicht
[Musik]
die nase gebrochen die lippen zerrissen
das kind zerfetzt die zähne
ausgeschlagen
nach dem unfall traute sich die groß die
ärztin zwei monate nicht mehr einen
stall zu betreten
aber das so gezielt und mit so viel
power das hättest du nicht dass völker
und das hatten ja auch möglich das
gefühl sie hat sie hat mich meine
tochter und ich halte es doch die
[Musik]
annina roma war als mädchen ein
richtiges rössli meidling ihr mann
kaspar ein kleintier arzt musste annina
rohners liebe immer schon mit ihren
pferden teilen
er fragt mich immer wieder was er so
macht man da so investiert viel zeit und
geld und emotionen
und als ich für mich schön ist grund
schwer
man ist ein sowie thomas ritter man
durchaus spieler mit ihnen und sie sind
sofort auf dich doch passiert sie waren
mit ihrer bis machen und sie sind
glücklich
richtig kooperativ das schön
ihre pferde halten ja auch nach dem
unfall die angst vor den großen tieren
wieder abzulegen
es läuft schon von innen heraus und da
das hat so lang weiter
[Musik]
annina oder unterscheidet klar zwischen
haus- und nutztieren pferde zum spielen
kühe und rinder für die produktion von
milch und fleisch
das ist braucht ich kann meine
schlachthof in finanz geschlachtet und
der schlacht gestanden und die haube
auf dem nächsten hof wartet bauer
rebellion hart seine kuh vreni ist
kerngesund bis auf eine einzige sitze
die keine milch mehr liefert darum
sollten jetzt in den schlachthof
[Musik]
annina rohner kennt berlin hat seit
beginn ihrer karriere eine frau groos
tierarzt war für viele bauern am anfang
ein novum und nur schwer vorstellbar
und dann ist da nur einige war es ein
aufgegangen ich mit mir in südafrika
ganz was ich habe das wirklich
aber das ist nun aber zeichnen und
bahnkritiker audio wenige moment wo sie
den beruf wirklich braucht und das ist
das was denken sie dass man sehen wie er
erklärt was für vorteile von marin hunt
hat das ist jemand förderstunden getan
wo man vorteile
annina rohner ist unterwegs in ihrem
revier wohnt um das bachtal im zürcher
unterland
sie besucht pro tag etwa sechs bauern
mit den meisten von ihnen verbindet sie
eine jahrelange freundschaft mit bauer
edle besuchte sie schon den kindergarten
seine kuh hat zwillinge geboren aber nur
eine nachgeburt ausgestoßen an in arona
soll die reste der zweiten platz und da
rausholen was sie genau solche momente
vor denen die groß tierärztin seit ihrem
unfall besonders respekt hat sie muss
ich das mal so wenn überwiegende
absolute die kontaktiert und um das wäre
durch die radikale schmerzhafte
situation schnell sich wären also das
wird eine natürliche beweglich aber wenn
sie durch gott so breitbeinigen statisch
nicht zu groß
ich sehe trotz aller vorsichtsmaßnahmen
an ihn aruna sagt sie sei nicht mehr
dieselbe person wie vor dem unfall
danach ist nirgendwo
sofort denkt jetzt 50 und als ich das
nie ein thema wäre und boni damit will
auch gut machen
auch zu hause wird sie gebraucht
ihr viertes pferd stelle hat hufrehe
eine schwere entzündung an den vorder
rufen ein krankes pferd im eigenen stall
das macht dann in arona persönlich
schwer zu schaffen denn pferde mit
dieser krankheit müssen oft
eingeschläfert werden
hoffen und bangen um das eigene pferd
die groß tierärztin fühlt sich der
heimtückischen krankheit ihres pferdes
ausgeliefert
das individuum so wie gott sei jetzt das
ist mir egal
also das macht mich traurig
sony alles ausgeschöpft und krediten
schön war das provisorium
seit der geburt der beiden kinder
übernimmt bei der familie wohne eine
angestellte am morgen den haushalt
tochter lea wohnt noch zu hause
heute sitzt auch annina rohners mutter
mit am tisch der sohn absolviert gerade
die rekrutenschule in der tierarzt
familie ist der umgang mit dem tod alles
andere als ein tabuthema habe mit ihrem
abitur gehört das fundament für schließt
sind also ich bin sicher sogar die
chance ist vielleicht zehn haben mir mit
immer husten und prusten familie oder
auch lea studiert tiermedizin
sie will aber nicht gross tierärztin
werden sie will sich den kleinen tieren
widmen wie ihr vater
nach der schuld einfluss genau in der
berufswahl war sehr schlechte beton wenn
sie probieren einfluss nehmen daraus
morgens um 7 uhr haben bereits die
ersten bauern angerufen das gehört zum
alltag der groß tierärztin
[Musik]
mutter sein und stets für die bauern
erreichbar bleiben beruf und familie zu
vereinen das viele in den letzten 25
jahren nicht immer leicht verständlich
still und sich von ihren tifosi fuhr so
lange druck
und dann bin ich halt grad gange und
desktop gang hat sie warteten
ein bauer berichtet von einem problem in
seinem stall eine kuh sollte karl bahn
aber das kalb stecke im geburtskanal
fest
eine lebensbedrohliche situation ein
notfall
früher übernahm annina rhone oft den
pickel dienst auch in der nacht seit dem
unfall nimmt sie es ruhiger und
überlässt die nacht einem tierarzt
kollegen in der gegend
frank ritter gegen boere minuten später
ankunft auf dem hof stadt zug albern ist
die kuh vreneli noch gemütlich beim
morgen als annina rohner im stall von
bauer david schellenberg eintrifft und
nach und nicht einfach ist schnitt mit
den meisten siegen
ich mache das schließlich sind übrigens
im bergsport der besucher geburtshilfe
im kalten stahl bei null grad annina
rohner realisiert das vreneli des kalbes
sterngucker und in steißlage unmöglich
selber gebären kann
dies wäre friedl ist siebtes kalb noch
scheint sie aber nicht wirklich carbon
zu wollen
was gerade so drauf wenn sie somit blog
systeme sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zwei weitere bauern kommen zur
unterstützung
die zeit drängt denn das kalb group im
geburtskanal zu ersticken
und ich hoffe mal geschlagen
ich kann ja gut trainiere ja
aber hat endlich sind und nicht gott
kein kunde könnte nochmal das ist mal
eine sieht diese schöner als der arzt
ohne grund und märkte beim wirklich
braucht
auch durch auf dem oberloh stieß hatte
ich mir schon gedanken gemacht so
zusammen etwas machen und wie sich ja
und das ist jetzt wirklich also als ich
natürlich nicht ich habe am ende
gegangen
das training ist karl bis gesund und
wurde valentin getauft
ein paar wochen später treffe ich janina
rohner wieder bei ihrem stall daniel
badraun für große wollen auch in einer
hütte befindet jung zum sterben
annina rohner macht weiter als gros der
ernsting nicht nur aus leidenschaft für
ihren beruf sondern auch weil sie etwas
gelernt hat mit ihrer angst umzugehen
ist schoss er in dallas und psychische
das ist die verletzlichkeit wenig spüren
und mit der einfach nur das andere
projekt zimmer zum beispiel mit der
ausbeute mit ihren schweizer
meisterschaft oder die stadträte dass
das mein vater und druck da oben waren
im hintergrund
[Musik]